yeah that was so trippy so I I was
eating a dog's penis they've got this
thing called a baculum which is like
they have a bone inside in my head I was
like oh it's just it's like my penis and
I just bit straight through it and like
almost like chipped a tooth on a dog's
penis
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm Conan and I'm joined what's
going with the boys Scott and Joey and
today we have two special guests once
again we have Alex reminded a thing and
boy boy and Alexa from boy boy how do
you introduce like each other like
normally yeah you have a separate thing
and then you both have a joined thing
together it's yeah we haven't decided
we've probably got to work it out for
tax reasons as well can you not state
that publicly oh yeah but you definitely
don't have a tax problem you double
claim everything right yeah yeah so you
guys you guys yeah you guys do um
interesting I feel like every Aussie
Creator does uh something that is kind
of a bit more unusual
um I think boy boy focuses more on
political stuff and I do the thing
focuses more on uh destructive uh
creative stuff would you say how would
you describe your own content to our
audience for it goes hand in hand I do
the politics and he teaches kids how to
make weapons to use you know in the
eventual uh Revolution
we're like you don't have to State this
my stuff is just kind of like I usually
describe it as like MythBusters but for
with with a guy who doesn't actually
know how to make anything
MythBusters if they were deranged and
focused on weapons yeah yeah it's kind
of trying to discover I don't know what
I'm doing learning along the way failing
most of the time so much so that anytime
I make something successful my audience
is like whoa like amazing
um show me your highlights involve
making uh hermit shells uh weaponers
yeah turned hermit shell into a weapon
yeah the hermit crab one right yeah yeah
uh your ceiling fan into a weapon yep
um I gotta ask how close have you come
to like injuring or like seriously
harming yourself yeah because I like to
I like to describe I did a thing as try
not to die challenge level of stream
it's just what it is it's like it's hard
it's easy enough to die in Australia as
you were just like let's just up
which is not exciting enough yeah well I
think I must just be delusional because
I want to say like not very close at all
but everyone keeps telling me you're so
close to dying I'm like every video you
are yeah I don't know what it looks like
to you but I hate being next to that
thrive
I think the closest is probably anything
to do with um blank blank rounds um I
did two videos uh using like blank
rounds which and it's just like there's
such a crazy amount of power there that
you know if something goes wrong or gets
diverted towards you he'll just go
through you well that's because it's
called a gun right yeah
yeah
but probably that yeah so what would you
think is like the craziest most
dangerous Contraption you've come up
with in your opinion oh I think it would
probably be one that I I did and I was
like no I won't muck around with that
before and it's with electricity
um and I did that uh we're halfway
through doing it I realized how
dangerous it actually was that it's like
well because I realized I didn't take
you that long
yeah
so and that's yeah I realized I'm not
smart enough to do that in a state yeah
I mean like like a Electro boom yeah
yeah you should muck around with stuff
that if you make one mistake you die
instantly that's that's my yeah it seems
like he knows what he's doing but it's
still dangerous you get a lot of views
though for that that one video yeah yeah
it'd be great to be the biggest video on
YouTube it's got to be in 4k at least as
well so 4K
um but you you guys on your so that you
do the channel called boy boy and this
kind of started after your channel right
um
it was just terribly unpopular for years
it shows how much I did my research
um but I think the first time I'd seen
anything of your channel and I thought
it was fake at first because I thought
there's no way this could be real they
you both went and I'm not mistaken you
both went to North Korea just to get a
haircut yeah yeah and I'm sure you've
I'm sure this has been like the Press
thing you always used to talk about like
yeah tell us about North Korea but like
I mean why the [__] did you do that oh
that was our first ever video as well
yeah yeah it's like a debut on YouTube I
think we were we wanted to go to North
Korea for tourism and um
just casually just just casual it's so
weird like you just hear so many stories
about it yeah how it's this kind of
mystical place with these crazy rules so
like we wanted to know is this true like
right yeah and then ended up just making
a video out of it like that was our
first ever thing on YouTube how are you
be able to film anything that were they
not like super strict about to be fair I
think there's a lot of misconceptions
about the place like it was the filming
was really chill over there just because
I mean you're on a guided tour
essentially they want you they want you
feeling like they want everything they
show you they're like show the world
this place is a paradise yeah yeah yeah
so if if one of our viewers wanted to go
to North Korea for tourism which I'm
sure like a lot of you guys watching are
what's like the process of like getting
the Visa and like getting over to North
Korea it's honestly easier though
exactly like when the North Korean
tourism board it's
honestly easier than any other country
we've gone to just because
it's so easy to do because their tool
companies are set up to do all of it and
I think we paid it was kind of pricey
for what we were poor students at the
time but we paid like a thousand bucks
for five days but you just send off your
details to this Chinese company
there are some dodgy bits like um oh
when you got that call in the morning
yeah yeah we well there was a couple of
things so the lead up to this scary call
in the morning was um they said you can
take photos of anything but the one
thing we don't want you to do is take
photos of the military
um so after a day being now I was like
well I'm gonna take photos of the
military so I just started taking photos
of the military and then one time they
saw me doing that
um so they started they asked if they
could go through my camera and then they
were going through my camera looking for
the photos of the military to delete
that but it's really funny because you
know how um if you record a video it has
a thumbnail yeah which the thumbnail was
there and they thought that was the
photo so they were just like why is this
guy taking photos of the ground like
right I didn't look through any of my
videos but they deleted some photos of
the military
um and then so that kind of put me on
their radar so then I was a bit stressed
like oh I've pissed them off you did the
best emotional manipulation on them that
was insane they saw stopped going
through your camera because he started
crying yeah I started crying
the camera
because they started deleting photos of
the travel and I took this photo of this
like really like this boy was sitting
down at the river and he was like
fishing I took a photo and I thought it
was like they deleted it and then I
started getting tears in my eyes that
they like they stopped they stopped
deleting so brutal but like they just
see a grown man crying
that's where the compassion kicks in
yeah what are monsters
don't worry about the Press though yeah
it's weird that we worry about the Press
when they're just arresting other people
yeah yeah oh my gosh this is weird that
they'd care about that yeah we like all
the tourists kind of stay in the the one
like specific tourist Hotel yeah right
and like you never really know what's
going on everyone's kind of assuming
that it's all bugged and they're
listening to you and stuff and then one
time we were out we're like privately
talking we're like okay if it is bugged
let's just tonight when we go back we'll
just talk to each other in gibberish all
night
um just in our room and hopefully
there's a there's a North Korean person
behind the scenes like flicking through
the translator
we did not give up for like hours just
saying nonsense
it's great so how closely were you guys
monitored were you guys allowed to leave
the hotel room at all kind of like
quarantining we could just walk around
the hotel we paid a bit extra to do like
a private tour for the last days and
then that's like more or less they said
it was a walking tour of the city and we
imagined oh you just get to walk but it
was like they took us to a street and
then the two guides walked down the
street to the end and then back up to
our starting point yeah and it was like
yeah it's a very restricted you don't
get to see very much no um they're
showing you what they want you to see
right the good parts but was it good the
good parts or was it just kind of like
that it was actually fine I mean like
yeah a lot of the good parts seem fairly
nice
um and that's the best it gets I guess
so yeah yeah yeah yeah but the one weird
thing was I think they've got this
um Vision that they're they're actually
like this best in the world kind of
YouTube yeah and so some of the photos
that they had issues with like Alex
taking a photo of that kid they were
just like oh he's he's Barefoot you
can't have that you know that looks he
looks poor and it's just like dude
people don't wear shoes Alex never wears
shoes off to Australia one time and also
the kid was like swimming in the river
with no rubbish and we just came from
China where everything's like covered in
rubbish and we're like no this this
actually looks pretty chill yeah yeah I
feel like calm down to go through China
to get into nothing yeah yeah
how was how's the food there I'm curious
uh I mean it I don't think it's a fair
judgment because we you obviously paid
money and yeah I think they would
obviously it was delicious it was just
like did you guys go to like a local
restaurant or something or whatever they
took you to yeah
right right because I don't think there
are local restaurants
I I actually I don't think I've ever
told this story on the podcast before
but um so it's this is like one of the
weirdest experience I've ever had right
so I was um this was when I was living
in Thailand and uh I was out with Sydney
at the time and we were walking around
and we were just like trying to find a
restaurant we were just in like the
middle of Bangkok uh and we see this one
massive restaurant and we rest uh we
recognize that it's like a Korean
restaurant so we're like great I'm
craving Korean let's uh let's try going
in
um and then we we head in and then
something's like something's like off
because we go in and it's a Saturday
night it's a massive [__] restaurant
and it's completely empty right right
and then we uh the servers come up
um and we soon realized is that we're in
Thailand so we expect them to at least
speak Thai or their second language a
lot of people speak English they did not
speak any Thai or any English at all uh
and so and for some reason all of the
girls uh they were all girls there all
of the girls who were serving us had
like this look like
um like they had a gun pointed at him or
something like that and it was and it
was super super weird so we got we go
into this restaurant and uh they serve
us
um and they were and there's like two
items on the menu or something and one
and I was like what the [__] is going on
here right uh so the only person who
spoke Thai there was the manager who
kind of didn't really know what was
going on uh she she was like uh I asked
her well what's uh what's uh what do you
recommend on the menu and she was like I
don't [__] ask the girls and so I try
like communicating with these girls oh
what do you what do you want on uh what
do you want on the menu and uh I was
like uh is it okay if I leave
um to like the manager and uh she
translates to that to the girls and she
um and the girls like no please please
please don't leave uh I'll I'll get you
this this I recommend this uh it's okay
I'll I'll get you this right now and uh
so we uh we get this like I think it's
like a chicken soup or something
uh and the entire time the girls are
like I don't know the girls just look
scared something was off for this
restaurant and in the end they ended up
double charging my cards and I tried
explaining hey I think you've double
charged my cards and they're like no we
haven't and I explained to manager
you've double charged my card and she's
like I can't do anything about this what
the [__] I reck I actually stealing
Rockets I recommend you just leave right
now and so and so we leave and I'm like
that's a weird [__] experience and so
we Google it
and we find out that it is a
state-funded North Korean restaurant and
we we are just like walked into a North
Korean state-funded restaurant and I was
like I didn't know this existed you know
crazy yeah yeah they're like like
basically like they're kind of held
hostage but yeah I heard about this
because I think there's a video probably
like [__] half as interesting did it
or something about how yeah the Korean
North Korean government funds like
restaurants of North Korean food to kind
of get people to appreciate the culture
more yeah but I'm surprised it's bad
service because like we had the opposite
in North Korea where it was like
so like obsessed on making everything
perfect that it was just like almost
freaky in the other direction right
right this is too much like chill out
maybe it's because you guys were in the
mainland right so yeah they had like a
standard to fill up where it's like you
know them in Thailand they're just like
No One's Gonna [__] walk in here they
know yeah also I bet they spoke fluent
Thai and English they were just trying
to scam you know
we're gonna [__] with this guy really
hard
oh my God that's terrifying was there
anything about North Korea that
surprised you guys that you weren't
expecting
I think well some I mean the
relationship with the leader was pretty
confronting what you expect yeah because
we went there to try and kind of like
you know look at it from a pretty like
neutral point of view and try to like
maybe dispel some of the western things
right um stories about North Korea but
yeah the stuff with the leader where
like every single person has the
leader's face and they're viewed as a
God yeah
um and there was some Hilarious Moments
where we went to the Museum of
friendship where they had they just want
to cry like
the place where there was all the gifts
that Kim Jong-un had received from
leaders around the world because
everyone loves him yeah they're best
mates and one of them was like a gift
from the Sam's the CEO of Samsung from
Korea and she shows us this cabinet and
she was like this is the all the gifts
from the CEO of Samsung and inside the
cabinet was just Apple computers from
like the 90s it's like the latest
Samsung technology and we were just like
trying not to laugh you're like they
just how do they don't know like they
had another one there it's just so hard
because you see how Earnest these people
are who are telling you this stuff I'm
like I cannot because they genuinely
believe it yeah yeah they have this
portrait there that he was gifted I
forgot from who and it's like this is
our dear leader riding a tiger in a suit
of armor smoking a cigarette and I was
just like and he's on top of a mountain
smoker he's just showing us something
and we're just like trying not to laugh
so hard like oh my God these are just
just get so they're just like proudly
showing everything off and a lot of them
are just [__] weird
they don't know any better all right
something about Mausoleum or something
oh yeah because like the the dad and the
Grandad so yeah
they're embalmed over there and um
two shorts North Korea version it was so
bizarre because we go there to like
you're doing to pay your respects and
um and you uh we get out like I don't
know how far away it was like a cool
kilometer away from the actual Mausoleum
you don't actually go when you go into
this like underground bit and you're on
travelators like the and you stand on
there and they're going slower than
walking pace and it's just the North
Korean national anthem blaring and
you're literally standing on that
travelator for like an hour it was like
half an hour and they made us standing
16 so four by four people and we had to
just stand still as we like floated down
this elevator with like pictures of uh
just North Korean Landscapes and then we
got to the end and there was this you
get to these different rooms where like
one of them had um like brushes on the
floor that like clean your feet and then
you go to another room that blows all
like the dust stuff you can be nice and
clean before you see the guys
when you finally get there it's like
it's so sad you've got it's all there
with a bunch of other North Koreans and
like everyone's crying it's like oh no
these guys are dead
um
you've got guards like armed guards
around around them and like the guards
are crying like the guy's like wiping
away his tears and they're like you're
there every day like
I was really lucky because I had a bit
of a cold so I was like sneezing in
teary the whole time it's like this
great I'm fitting in perfectly I'm
legitimately crying yeah so we got him
to North Korea
you know because obviously I imagine
there's something in your passport
that's like I went to North Korea yeah
if you've had any questions in America
yeah we are like why do you go we had to
get interviewed um because normally
Australians can go like on an Esther
visa to America but we can't we have to
go and get interviewed by the American
guards who asked the weirdest [__]
questions
which was just so weird and they're so
strangely so intimate about it so just
because you went to North Korea yeah
it's like what do you think I'm a spy
the worst spy in the world what kind of
questions are they asking like oh just
why did you go there did you enjoy it
did you enjoy it I was like what if I
say yes about his wife so I was like it
was weird yeah you're trying to like do
you want me to say it was bad
that was just the most pointless
questions yeah like well you're not
getting anything out of this it's
pointless but they're also just like
angry at you like it was like am I
wasting your time
I just loved it that we're getting
interviewed by Americans about North
Korea I look behind the guy interviewing
me there was a massive portrait of
Donald Trump looking like Kim Jong-un I
was like it's exactly the same it's the
same place they made us like they took
all our stuff and like um we were like
they took they took our shoes and we
just walked through the embassy Barefoot
and we're like wow yeah yeah it was
pretty hectic it's not true that would
not be allowed yeah yeah no no shoes
Jesus so do you get a question every
time you go to America or uh no it's
just the once when we got but once the
Visa expires we'll have to do that again
[Music]
so that just set the president for your
channel then it's like okay we went to
North Korea uh that kind of like what's
next
did you make the channel remind me like
I want to get political and talk about
it kind of have opinions and things yeah
I think that was that was the the goal
of it um kind of try to make politics
funny try to try to brainwash people who
don't want to hear anything about
politics
yeah because I saw the video where it
was like how how much money can you
launder in there
this guy um Troy stalls he's like a
whistleblower
um he's a dude who used to work for the
the gambling I guess gambling industry
to like check if they're
um doing what is it if they're complying
with money laundering regulations in
Australia yeah yeah it turns out all
these casinos aren't they're like
actively letting money laundering happen
because they make money from it and you
know yeah all this stuff and he reveals
this and then they like sue the [__] out
of him and like this guy's like getting
[__] up
yeah yeah yeah
I just want to talk about Chad showed
his ass on the last one so yeah
and like this guy's getting screwed in
here I don't know it was a very very sad
situation so we like kind of came in and
got him to show us how you launder money
in a casino yeah and just how easy it is
it's incredibly it's crazy it's so easy
that you just you go to a poker machine
you put in as much money as you want
take notes because
then you hit a button and it will just
give you a receipt which you can take up
to the counter and they will give you
clean bills not only clean bills but a
receipt that says you won this from
gambling and then there's tax free money
yeah well it's tax free and you can do
it on a on a on a thing up to seven
thousand dollars and you can do that
onto multiple machines so we easily did
like twenty five thousand dollars in you
know in in like two three hours but the
thing is we won't even just we at first
we were just seeing if we could do it
and it was fine then after that we're
like oh if it's this easy like maybe
pull up the stakes and we're just
wearing different costumes like you yeah
the shirts or like I'm laundering money
right now yeah like dressed as like a
robber in there it was just like it
doesn't matter like I don't care yeah oh
my God have you ever been contacted by
like the authorities or anything yeah we
got banned from the casinos in Australia
for a different reason for another video
where you uh because I guess during
covid you were seeing if they were
complying with covert rules yeah and
then you went in with a fever yeah
you hit you heat up your arm when we had
a hats on and we put heat packs under
the hat so and then we took off the hats
just before so they didn't see the heat
packs yeah right and my head was
something around 50 degrees
Yeah Yeah and they kind of scanned our
heads and then we're like oh just wait
here for a minute and then they did that
and then just let us in with like 50
degree fevers yeah you're wearing like a
hospital yeah Alexis down with like a
drip yeah
I'm like yeah yeah I did but I'm feeling
lucky you know
I would just like oh I just get changed
first and then you can go in yeah that
was it it's just so [__] insane and
then recently I had the police come to
my mom's house
um oh wait after that we got banned from
the casino oh yeah all right conclusion
contact us why did you get back sorry
why did you uh the police get called to
your mom's house it was because of a
video I made five years ago I made a um
a gun I don't like saying oh my God
the device that's prepared yes a
propelling device that propelled tampons
um so it was like a Nerf propeller yeah
that shot tampons and I made it five
years ago and it was horrible it didn't
work well at all I said wait why do they
give a [__] about that because they came
and they were telling my mom they were
just like oh it's so dangerous what Alex
has done because what if like the bike
he's got a hold of it or someone else
got a hold of it and it was just like
the bikies have real guns yeah like what
are they going to do with this so
tampons cost like a million dollars a
cheaper
and it didn't work very well I almost
felt like telling them like no I could
make much better things now but I was
like
a hammer right now
wait so how did that go then so yeah
image explaining to your mom and then
they just left so I didn't I I destroyed
the device very quickly after making it
so luckily I didn't have it
um and then they just kind of they were
pretty chill about it there were two
female cops which was very funny that
they were looking for the tampon
but then they they just said like oh if
he has has it there's a thing in
Australia called a gun amnesty so if you
make a device or you have a unregistered
firearm you can give it into the police
without questions right
um I don't have the device I like I'm
saying this a lot dude
and then so then they'll I just told
them um that I didn't have the device
anymore and they were happy right so
yeah I don't have it yeah so I'm sure
you would know this best but what like
technically is like the definition of a
gun in the eyes of the Australian law
it's pretty vague in terms of it's like
is my opinion of it like I thought
my legal opinion is a lawyer I thought
it was something that needed a trigger
um then that uses any kind of anything
to project something right
yeah yeah but it turns out it's not that
you don't need a trigger it's just
anything that projects anything out of a
heavy clip okay so Nerf gun a Nerf gun
was a gun so it's like an air rifle is a
gun a blue a blue a blow gun right what
is a gun
you're projecting something it's insane
rules yeah
um so it's like yeah so so where do they
draw the line how much is it very
intentional yeah to just kind of crack
down whoever they want to know probably
because if you look up what's illegal
here like nunchucks or legal throwing
stars or illegal knives so it a lot of
the stuff you've got that big nunchuck
massacre in Tasmania
nunchucks are illegal in a lot of places
actually oh yeah why what they just hurt
yourself
I swear I was going to buy them on
wish.com one time and I like live and
people were like no don't do that I was
like it's two planks of wood yeah how is
this like who I I can own a knife I feel
like politicians just watched one too
many Bruce Lee yeah yeah if he can do
that anyone can do that
yeah
also obviously there's obvious reasons
if you know yeah brass knuckles are made
for just beating people up like yeah
okay no no okay if if I'm in a street
fight and someone brings out some
[__] nunchucks I'm getting the [__]
out because they're not dangerous
because if someone actually pulls them
out and does a trick you'll be like this
guy's serious I'm leaving yeah brass
knuckles they're hidden until someone
hits you in the face with them yeah yeah
that's true but that you know it's
because nunchucks have a skill ceilings
so I'm like if someone brings out I'm
like I'm getting
nunchucks in a fight if they weren't
competent that's what I'm saying though
that's what I'm saying that's my exact
point
yeah you know brass knuckles you know
you know how brass knuckles works you
know nunchucks I have no idea how the
[__] that works so speaking of fighting
you both also were going to fight and
then both got [__] up nunchucks
that was actually not knowing how to use
brass knobs I tried to trade boxes yeah
so you were in the first Creator clash
and you were gonna do the second one
yeah unfortunately got a concussion and
you're going to do chest boxing against
met and then you've got a concussion as
well but you gave him a concussion
we just sound like the biggest idiots
the worst part about um when Alex Alex
knocked me out it was um we were
sparring all the time and um at one
point like five weeks before the match
because he's just a big big and strong
guy Alex and he yeah he punched me like
in the chest and he broke one of my ribs
and it was like it was five weeks out
from the thing and I looked it up online
it's like okay it takes five weeks for a
broken web to heal like I'm in this I've
still got it yeah it's like we can keep
training but no more body shots just
headshots just headshots and then like
pseudo lady just knocked me out and it's
just like okay so headshot's aren't safe
yeah it's just it's such a dumb sport
that like I mean there's obviously ways
to train relatively safe at the end of
the day it's like you're just getting
hit in the head yeah yeah it's just and
then when it happened to me I was like
this isn't worth it right I'm scared the
crap it's [__] scary and he he was
bad like we had it where we were having
a party at the house and um he wasn't
drinking at all because he was concussed
and I went to the bathroom came back and
then Alexa was talking to some people
but he was just kind of talking
gibberish and he sounded really drunk
and I was like oh Alex is [__] he's so
drunk and I was like wait he's not
drinking because I was like he's just
that cute ass I was scared for a while
though it's like first couple of weeks
where I was like slowing my words I was
I thought like it just the rest of my
life
um
you just get punched and how long does
it last like what like this this was
like two months of non-stop Jesus um
that's not worth it [__] that yeah for
like you know 10 minutes
it's dangerous because so many people
are into the Creator boxing so yeah and
we don't really know how [__] up
everyone's gonna be because with
professional fighters yeah when they're
50 or 6 they just can't speak yeah we
haven't had like a proper debilitating
injury yet and I'm sure one's gonna
happen some creators gonna get like
messed up forever like yeah when you get
one concussion getting a second one it's
way easier yeah yeah
and I guess because everyone's not
really a professional fighter which the
[__] even as a professional no just
someone who's been concussed 100 times
like you know yeah it seems pretty rough
I mean some of the fights look pretty
bad afterwards yeah you see people who
are pretty [__] up yeah oh God no yeah
we were making videos like two days ago
why are we yeah you already have a
career like yeah you're not gonna you're
not trying to be a professional boxer
yeah but it must have been some kind of
like [__] I wish I could have fought in
that there I trained yeah that's the
thing is it's real love hate where it's
like just the ultra competitiveness and
the real nature of it is just something
else like it almost feels like it
activates this kind of Primal part of
your brain like when I had it it was
just like no thoughts just focusing on
kill man
with this weird like part of your brain
it's fun to be there for a bit how long
have you train how long do you train for
the first grader Clash I think I was
training for like maybe seven months six
months and there's a lot of like the
sparring was terrifying like doing like
because I'd I'd been in fights but never
thrown a punch before that where it was
just like mates being [__] in a bar
and then yeah but it was always like the
option was like if someone's gonna punch
me you run away without having to sit
stand in a ring and face some big guy
that wants to punch you who knows how to
punch it's like the most the scariest
thing how hard did you go in training
compared to like the actual event itself
because if you can get concussion
training that you obviously are going
pretty [__] hard yeah my trout War
for me because my fight I didn't get
punched
I'm gonna try to use much much worse
punched over and over and over again
you're like oh this is easy mode now
that was the first one how long were you
training for the chess boxing more that
wasn't that long it was like three and a
half months that's still a long time
yeah it was great though I love like
because I've never been an athlete yeah
it is pretty nice to have that kind of
um regimented life have like a big goal
and like have someone on the other side
of the world who wants to beat the [__]
out of you like it's such a good
motivator to do anything
I want to get myth to beat me up just
for like just for cleaning my [__]
together
for making a video oh yeah I gotta make
a video yeah because you guys ever do it
yeah no hell no maybe I mean after after
hearing these stories
I feel like it's just like a good excuse
to get in shape yeah obviously the
biggest reason yeah but you can do that
without getting punched in the headers
yeah but like sometimes it's called
going to the gym but what better
motivation is there than like the danger
of getting hit in the [__] audience
you know that is that is the best
motivator you can I've never been more
motivated in my life you want to be that
guy who loses in the first round right
like that's a powerful motivator yeah to
get you to [__] train I I would have
liked to have done it but
um yeah I have like a blood condition so
no one will allow me to and also I
shouldn't because I'm it'd be dumb what
you went training for the slap boxing
that you did no I I just [__] went up
and did that that was like last minute
yeah yeah because what you were it was
meant to be xqc or something oh yeah
yeah you remember right because we were
there yeah because I remember I was
pissing and he was like I don't know who
I'll ask you know I was like I might ask
Alex and I was like I don't mind doing
it as well like I was like I was sure so
that was all last minute but you were
great I like your stage presence up
there I was just like he looks like this
is WWE
awesome
that's very nice of you yeah I was so
[__] last minute you know just kind
of was like all right let's we were
sitting together yeah yeah drinking
beers and then suddenly the production
comes up to me he's like are you ready I
was like go ahead two hours to go up and
I started shooting myself [__] I came
here to like hang out and just like have
a good time and drink beers and then I
and then I have to go out but it was fun
though it was definitely a good time
yeah I didn't expect to go up at all
since you were training for the chess
boxing uh because I talked to like a
bunch of creators who were part of the
chess boxing event and there seemed to
be a disparity between how much training
you put into boxing versus how much
people are putting into the chess aspect
of things did you actually like practice
any chess style I love chess like um
my dad's like a competitive chess guy
um so like I've been your dad's like
1400 isn't it oh wow yeah he's a he's a
big guy well inboxing
he beats you as well
one of the queen that was my kind of
secret weapon I've been right well
myth's chest was [__] awful awful
yeah
you could have won with a concussion I
think yeah
and the best thing about that was
hearing that Ludwig had lied to you
about me but then Ludwig had liked a
myth about you myth thought you were six
one yeah you're actually six three and
what you thought he was I thought I
thought he was shorter than he was and
um I thought some uh Ludwig told me that
he was like almost like 10 kilograms of
lighter and then you both found out at
the same time and you're both like right
we look at each other we're like wait a
minute
very very funny so no no no more boxing
I don't think so I think I'm done unless
there's someone that's just like a
ridiculously easy
I actually hate for some reason I feel
like boxing if you actually hate someone
then you'd be like well there's a
purpose here but you hear boxes be like
oh you want a box of friends it's like
why do you want to give a friend a
concussion no no you should box someone
you hate yeah a lot of those matches for
like they're friends of each other and
it's like no like me and Fitz and I
think that would have been like
a [__] up fight like yeah we're both
lanky he's like six foot six I think it
would have just been both of us being
really badly but also you guys are like
in love with each other which is like
yeah one of you is going to go less hard
one of you is not going to be able to to
be that angry yeah like they're doing
Bruno at the end
we were talking about that
just start having sex
in Florida as well
I mean they [__] sing the national
anthem yeah yeah let's do it let's [__]
oh
yeah so maybe maybe something that's a
great perfect great yeah it was fancy
yeah yeah good way to launcher well I
don't think that's great
money's getting low we gotta fund it
let's let's get it out this episode is
sponsored by boxers what should love is
the experience of facing authentic
Japanese snacks candies and teas Source
directly from centuries old small family
businesses right to your door their
mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic foods and stories with
the world what do we have this month
let's check it out because at boxer
every single month comes with a brand
new theme this month we have luminous
Tokyo when you order your first box you
the first box you'll receive is called
The Seasons of Japan think their
greatest hits of flavors and snacks and
then following that you'll get a themed
box every single month like the boys
just introduced so we got right here a
Hana okaki from Hiroshima these are kind
of like rice crackers but we'll show you
flavor that looks good you had a crunch
that sounds amazing
Connor I found a snack that I know you
will like it's a mekan snack Connor do
you wanna you wanna have a taste Corner
don't worry Connor I'll taste it for you
they're actually Mikan marshmallow oh
that's good but not only that every box
Zoo comes with its own tea pairing as
well we actually have Nikon tea right
here Mandarin team which is actually
very nice especially during the summer
time we've been living in Japan for
about four years now Joey longer but you
genuinely don't normally get to see
these kinds of snacks so even for us we
get to try something new with a box suit
so to get 15 off your own box to
Japanese snack box and supporting the
channel in the process use our code
trashtaste at boxer.com that's
b-o-k-s-u.com that is bokksu.com with
code trash taste for 15 off your first
order thank you very much boxing for
sponsoring us today back to the episode
you've also made a lot of videos uh
about guns in America as well both of
you right yeah you did the one where you
strapped an automatic gun to one of
those dogs that was the most terrifying
video I've ever seen as you did the
video in the same Ranch kind of talking
about guns yeah why people are obsessed
with guns yeah
um okay there's a lot to unpack where do
we start when okay I'm curious how the
[__] did you get one of those dogs how
did you convince someone to let you have
a dog it was pretty funny because it was
um one of the Boston Dynamics
yeah it's still a good dog
does the Ripoff versions of that docs
that seems like such a specialized test
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy to think that
this China probably saw it was like we
can do that for cheaper as well but we
can do it for cheaper
um but yeah it was funny because I hit
up the company which is I'm gonna say
their name because I find it funny to
piss them off uh uni tree and I was like
I was like oh can I do this I want to
put a gun on it and they're just like
first they were interested and then when
they heard the idea just no response
yeah so I tried contacting different
people no I wanted to but I found a man
who wanted to remain anonymous
you just named a random name yeah random
man and people were so pissed off was
that Anonymous but you named him it's a
joke
but yeah and then this guy really liked
the idea and really wanted to know what
would happen and he happened to be in
the same place no as uh in Texas as the
guy that had the guns was like this is
perfect
um so yeah we got in contact with him
got the the uh the dog and then went to
uh Brandon herrera's Place who's a big
gun YouTuber I've never heard of this
guy until yeah yeah
um and then you know put a machine gun
on the dog and it was terrifying there
was no it was a bad video like that oh
yeah that is so that you asked the most
dangerous thing that is the most the
scariest thing we're controlling the dog
via like a little Dicky it was the GoPro
app and the worst thing was that I was
like okay safety we're behind a mound so
if the dog flips over yeah it'll be safe
but the GoPro lost signal behind the
mound so I had to like stick my head up
with the GoPro looking and then when I
saw it shoot it would have to dodge but
obviously you can't dodge a bullet
yeah
it would have been too late so I was
like the dog was so unstable with like a
fully automatic weapon on top of it so
like any time it would burst fire the
dog would just like flip around and lift
up it would go just run back holy [__]
yeah
like how do you go about testing that in
a safe environment yeah
started with like one bullet in the in
the in the magazine single shot
um but still it's really scary just
really scary and that's like my videos
are scary but then being around
something that's well designed to kill
people yeah and then mucking around with
that is just like something else like
yeah so why well I thought it'd be like
propose an idea to the Americans who
seem very like willing to do anything
else besides like gun controls like
let's do an American idea then of like
machine gun on a robot dog to prevent
school shootings
it's like the political argument like
whenever a school shooting happens a lot
of people like oh the issue that we need
more guns yeah and it's like okay what
does that look like yeah let's do the
extreme of that you know robot dog in
the classroom with a gun just kind of
like you know just making fun of the
whole thing yeah it's funny how annoyed
Americans get it anything to do with
taking guns away because you get a lot
of heat for that video Yeah quite a lot
of heat
yeah I hadn't experienced that before
and I was kind of like it's scarier than
like the normal heat because all these
people have guns
and as well some of them because a lot
of them were in America but then I had
some Australians hit me up and be like
you know we've got guns here as well and
I was like well like it's funny to piss
someone off with a gun and their
response is like I'm gonna shoot you
yeah that's all I know I had a great
case for gun control here yeah yeah any
threats or anything like that or was it
yeah a couple of deaths rights and like
like what like how dare you put a gun on
a dog I'm gonna yeah yeah I'm gonna
shoot you yeah just talking about gun
rights and that kind of thing right yeah
right and you at the same place had a
video kind of just a more kind of
political and yeah with some of the
people on this gun
there's so many guns in America we're
just kind of trying to work out like
what the justification is and like a lot
of time they they push this thing where
it's like we need guns to protect
ourselves from like a tyrannical
government like a you know there'll
never be an evil government if we can
defend ourselves and then we're just
kind of analyzing that saying like I
don't know America's got like crazy
police like the biggest prison
population in the world but like
tyranny's already happening like what
are your guns like the guns are just a
hobby like yeah and these guys that say
they want to use their guns to protect
from the government they love the police
yeah that was the main point of being
like you're not you love the police the
police came over you'd suck them off
yeah
they're your buddies so it's just
pointing out that they're more of a
hobby we are seeing it and they have
like they're like so proud to show off
like guns from like World War II and
yeah like this is a Nazi gun it's like
why
do you have this no one needs this she's
like how do you have this and it's funny
when you get an obsession with Nazi
stuff because it was like that's a bit
weird
why did you have to bring that into it
yeah yeah yeah what I want to know is
how how you went from like guests like
making political videos together to you
kind of like doing I guess making death
machines like how how did that come
about oh so that was kind of like my
whole life I've just kind of he's made
I'm really interested in but yeah it's
not even a joke it's just like at school
I was the kind of known as the guy that
would blow things up I remember oh my
God like we would do like horrible
things like I don't know if I should be
saying this but like making letterbox
bombs and
and then sometimes you'd put a letterbox
bomb in someone's letterbox and then it
wouldn't blow up and then it was just
like it's like is that the movie The
Butterfly Effect yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the scene and like [__] now
there's this unexploded bomb in this old
woman's letterbox I'm like do I run back
and get it
yeah so it was because in Australia you
can't buy fireworks a bomb so I would
make um I don't know if I should say
actually how to make the Box
what is this thing so it's just like
basically it works a chemical reaction
that makes a gas in a it's a pressure
bot so instead of just like it's a gas
that expands and expands inside a
enclosed space and then when there's
enough pressure will blow up right right
this sounds [__] dangerous yeah yeah
it's like it's like when you put like
the dry ice in them it's exactly I think
it's exactly that but just with them
what the [__] were you doing in building
things because I just thought it was fun
and there's loud noises and I would muck
around with thermite I remember I um
you can just make it it's just um
yeah yeah but you could just make it and
then um I remember I would tell people
at school and then we came up with the
ideas of melting the school's gate
together so that we couldn't get back
into school or something and then we did
this it didn't work I just set the grass
on fire
no it's probably my school now finding
out though
I got asked you do you have any
background on like engineering or
science no no not at all that's probably
why I'm so bad at it that's the angle
right people people watch your channel
to see you get hurt and like do things
wrong or probably to be inspired that
like this guy that has no idea what he's
doing if he can make it then maybe I can
do something as well you know you sound
almost as insane as uh
I think Nile Reds actually knows me he
knows what he's doing but he's willing
to take more risk like he would talk
about his childhood and it was like yeah
I just love it it sounds very similar to
yours yeah yeah we're just getting like
farming the zinc from the batteries yeah
yeah yeah [__] it's wrong play games he
was telling us one time yeah I just uh I
almost set like a school on fire or
something just because I was like
[__] around I was like how did you
get to that point have you did you have
you have you ever had any bad almost
accidents like
growing up as a kid I feel like yeah I
had a lot of accidents when I was a kid
a lot yeah a lot of always like
cut fingers like [__] up toes from I'm
trying my worst accidents were not from
or I had a pretty good one where I um a
pretty good one with this with a spear
gun where I was like mucking around with
it as a child and I didn't really know
how to use things and I strapped the
speed gun down to a table I don't know
what I was trying to find out but I
thought I didn't know speed guns had
recoil so I put my face really close to
it shot the spear gun and goes back into
my mouth
split open my lip and my thing and I
remember just massive gash
um but no I think that's probably the
worst injury I've had so yeah where did
you grow up this was just in in Sydney
yeah but there's things to do in Sydney
right now
Joe Kitty can you attest to this well I
mean whereabouts in Sydney uh in the in
the suburbs like northern northern
suburbs like northwest suburbs of Sydney
really yeah because I'm from Northern
beaches really yeah so and like I'd
never heard anyone of your magnitude
without doing anything like that I'm
like you're making bombs yeah yeah we
would we did some pretty [__] up stuff
in high school friends since high school
yeah the thing is like before I met him
I wasn't doing any of this I was playing
World of Warcraft
but let me take you into my world we
used you were the kid that every other
parent was like do not hang out yeah
yeah yeah that was pretty bad
we we had it as well we used to play a
game should we talk about sogging what
the [__] yeah but I yeah I guess so I I
was more auxiliary to that game I never
did
what the [__] is bad I don't know I
don't know this game called sogging at
school where like we had nothing to do
like but we probably did have things to
do but we definitely thought it'd be fun
to go down to like the highway right we
would hide in the bushes and just throw
various objective objects of cars and
then the police would come and would run
away from the police and this was like a
every week thing
we had one friend that every time he'd
do a poo
it's on like a napkin and then throw it
at cars that's what monkeys do yeah
it's horrible and I still remember the
expression he threw under the truck and
this truck driver came out he was like
wow we just started chasing I was
screaming like you cheat on our truck or
something
this is the worst thing ever this is
really devolved
I didn't even really like it when we
were doing it I just wanted to have
friends
oh my God this is what you got to do
this is what everyone's doing yeah like
wow play discovers how to make friends
yeah
I guess this is how everyone makes
friends in Australia right just uh
together
that's kind of the origin of I did a
thing yeah right [__] throwing to
letterbox bombs too so you just wanted
to like yeah just like okay I want to
bring this hobby of mine and just uh
share with the world on YouTube so the
actual the like the actual origin was um
so yeah the experience of that and then
Alexa when I made boy and Alexa I think
went to Serbia for a year or six months
and then got into I was meant to be
there for like a very short time gone
into like a relationship and just ended
up there forever and I was like I'm not
waiting for this guy yes then I was like
after the boy boy and kind of realizing
a bit of how much potential YouTube had
I was like right I think I can try this
I was like what am I interested in I was
like making things and doing things so I
started that and I think I was at it for
like a year
um with relative success I got I think I
had 25 000 subscribers in the first year
and then the day after the first year
one of the videos caught on right and
then just Channel blow up and then which
which video was that I made a video
called how dangerous is a metal straw
which I tested um just water metal straw
would do to a human head if you fell on
it in your mouth
um yeah it's pretty bad yeah yeah it
goes straight through your head yeah
yeah what was the first contraption that
you made on YouTube then
a book that when you open it throws a
throwing knife into your face
now why on Earth would you need that I
just I don't know how I came up with
that idea
just thinking of yeah I mean no one
thinks the ideas that you think of
because no one should think yeah the
tricky is Alex you guys not many people
know this Alex actually does not know
how to read and you've had a vendetta
against books and he's just trying to
like pay back people who actually do
know how to read yeah yeah it was
probably something like that in my head
yeah
no a lot of the ideas I'm just like yeah
out of context I'm like what what does
this look like what is this do I look
like a psychopath thinking of this idea
like I think so the answer is yeah yeah
what I'm learning from most of the
science YouTubers is that there are like
us there are two science type YouTubers
or building or engineering whatever like
the the unhinged type and then like Mark
robber type yeah that are like we're
professional we do everything above
board and then you have all right let's
just explode things let's figure it out
let's make a gun out of tampons the
worst thing is like they all come up
with crazy things on their own but when
you get these science guys together it's
horrible I got the zoo like we were we
were staring staying at like an Airbnb
with a bunch of them together and you
went backyard scientists yeah just
pretty much destroyed the entire house
like within within within five minutes
they caused this explosion in the
backyard well I know within five minutes
I had stabbed Kevin in backyard
scientist maybe you stabbed Kevin by
accident how did you stab him because we
were in the house we were trying to we
hyped each other up and the house had
locked doors like every Airbnb does
right and we were like oh let's go lock
pick all the doors and just see go
rubbish through them through their
possessions like [__] horrible people
and in the process of trying to lock
pick I was using a knife to shimmy the
lock open I slipped and just stabbed
Kevin straight in the arm and just went
straight through his thing just hit his
bone and this was after five minutes and
we had this moment where we stopped and
looked at each other and were just like
why do we do this like how did we get
here like how did I stab you Kevin
that's not exactly the same brand of add
it's like
you enable each other yeah yeah it's
pretty bad yeah it's like when you see
like dog a dog looking into a mirror and
they're like
you made like his own rocket fuel yeah
Kevin's crazy man which is like what
Kevin's like the person I want to be in
terms of like he's level like he's
incredibly smart and just hyper focus on
something and just make ridiculous
inventions like his Tesla coil that
plays music and yeah I thought I've
never been a spiritual man when I saw
Tesla coil I thought I saw God
he was crazy have you guys heard them
play music yeah yeah yeah oh my God and
when you're in the same room as them it
does something where the air I think is
charged yeah so you feel like you know
your skin is literally has goosebumps
because there's static electricity like
pulling your hairs out of your body yeah
I uh I I recently like played around
with the Tesla coil because I I was
hanging out with this Japanese YouTuber
who's basically the equivalent of what
you do about Japanese what's his name uh
Sushi Ramen yeah yeah unfortunately yeah
yeah yeah so like he has a Tesla coil as
well and I went to his place to just
hang out with him make a video and he
was like oh let's try and cook
marshmallows with a Tesla coin and so
we're just standing there holding this
thing while this Tesla core is just
burning the [__] out of this marshmallow
and yeah as you said like I felt my
entire body just like get electrically
charged and I'm like this is not safe
yeah like I should not be in this room
right now yeah so is this a homemade
Tesla coil uh yeah yeah he had like made
a Tesla coil and I was like is this safe
and he's like well I'm not dead and I'm
like that's not that's not a guarantee
at all that's not that's not a good
barometer considering uh yeah if he
doesn't know what he's doing with
electricity like you said yeah but it's
a bit of survival of the fittest you
know if he's if he's lasted this long
that means there's the filter and he's
he's passing it yeah have you ever had
to do any like studying for like or just
like upping your knowledge for whatever
I talk [__] about myself a lot but I
have I have gotten a bit better at
making things in terms of like welding
and machining abilities right it's nice
and that now I can actually
work with something break it down and
turn it into parts that are usable and
having the ability to like just turn
metal into like bolts and threads and
cut stuff is pretty cool because you can
actually look at something like well I
can make all the parts to this just with
metal at home right and then learning to
weld is is nice because it's just so
strong and it's actually people talk
[__] about welding a lot we're like oh
you have to do it in this right way it's
like no you can just kind of get a stick
and go like this and it does just hold
together it's like it's nice how did you
come up with your ideas for what you
want to make or like your new videos
because it's sometimes I'm like okay
that kind of makes sense you know with I
look at Michael Reeves and I'm like okay
there's some logic there's it's like
batshit crazy logic but there's some
kind of logic and sometimes I look at
your videos I'm like what the [__] are
you trying what are you trying to
achieve what are you trying to improve
here I I think it's usually starting
from one place that's logical like
something will uh kind of spark a bit of
like a question in my mind right some
just something I've seen in the world
old or something someone says and then
you just kind of go from there you write
that idea down and then you just twist
it a little bit or tweak it a lot of it
comes from me thinking oh what would
people on YouTube like what's
interesting
um like I can open my life in danger
yeah I feel your videos are kind of like
the questions that like hi people like
ask each other except you make it a
reality yeah I feel like there's gonna
be a lot of videos where both of you
have been like we should make this and
you're like oh this is a terrible idea
we should not do this
coming up with the boy boy ideas is fun
because it's it's really like just like
I don't know trying to push like
political questions or things we're
interested in but you're like oh how can
we turn that into a political yeah yeah
yeah yeah like I saw you I I don't know
if this ended up being a trend but I saw
you snuck into like an arms dealer
convention or something it did it did
get a bit of a bit of people doing the
same thing talking about that and we had
a lot of people just make the exact same
video yeah yeah because I saw that one
video then my YouTube recommended was
like oh I snuck into a security
convention I sluck into an ex-convention
I don't know yeah which is very easy it
was crazy when I was doing it yeah it
was so easy but like I assumed that it
wasn't gonna work I'm like of course
it's not going to work why would I be in
there
um no one checks it so what what was the
process of like sneaking into this um
well I mean I was staking out the place
quite a bit I was thinking like do I
like jump the fence do I do this and
what I ended up doing was um after the
first day all the kind of arms dealers
had posted on Twitter being like I'm a
fun day at the festival and they had all
their lanyards there I'm like okay I
know what the lanyard looks like I'll
kind of copy it but for legal reasons I
couldn't copy it exactly because that's
like fraud so I just it was called land
forces and I just called it fake passes
and um there's like a QR code on there I
just put on a random website and I just
walked in and I think it's one of those
like and you get scanned and no one
checks anything and you go straight
through and it's just like I think the
way it works a lot of the security there
are terrified of you because you're some
like hot shot arms dealer like you know
you're gonna get them fired if they hold
you up too long
like you could potentially work for
Boeing yeah yeah like you're not going
to say no I think it's just like it's
just like confidence is like the biggest
part of it and like it is crazy like you
belong yeah I think the coffee is a big
trick coffee like walking in with a
coffee and a suit like people are gonna
be like that man belongs here he's late
and he's grumpy and he's tired and he
needs to be in a meeting it's like a
modern day equivalent of what the hive
is yeah yeah it's exactly it it's like
No One's Gonna question you like and the
[__] is also nice because you're
terrified in there and you always want
to shake and when you're holding
something at least you've got something
to do with your hands
did you get any did you get any Flack at
all for doing that or was it all just no
that was all fine I think that the nice
thing about arms deals is that like
everyone hates them
um
that was a that was an easier one
welcome to this sponsored segment
brought to you by cash app I would like
to remind you for a moment that I am a
gamer and what does a gamer need that's
right experience and thank God for me
cash app allows me to get that XP I need
to level up my life and it just made
that life grind a little bit easier with
tools for saving and spending it's the
best place for you to level up your
money and glow up your life listen I'm a
little guilty sometimes of forgetting to
pay people I I do it I do it but luckily
for me with cash app it's easy to settle
up those tabs all it takes to pay
someone is their phone number email or
their cash tag you can even scan their
QR code straight from the app and with
my reckless spending it's very fortunate
that cash have has a way for me to keep
track of my coin you'll see your balance
update immediately so you always know
when a payment has gone through from
security locks to data encryption cash
app uses Advanced features to keep you
and your money safe you can also browse
topics find resources or chat with a
human cash app support has all the
answers to your questions and I haven't
even mentioned the best part you save
money on everyday spending get exclusive
discounts with cash app pay and Cash
Card Cash app allows you you to bank the
way you want it's a faster simpler way
to bank without so many fees if you want
to level up your life you've got to
level up your money so download cash app
in the app store or the Google Play
Store using our Link in the description
down below with no hidden fees and a
free to order debit card it feels like a
cheat code for your finances back to the
episode all right so you've learned how
to launder money how to get in any
convention is there any other life hacks
you've learned from making your videos
what have we done what's something that
like you've figured out through your
videos that you're like this is [__]
but it's a common piece oh the money
laundering yeah obviously that one I
don't know like you know I forgot every
video I've done yeah
I think I've watched all of them or most
of them
um I think a big thing that from boy boy
is just how easy it is to to lie as any
kind of media company or or what what's
considered like a fact yeah that when
you actually look into you're like
there's no real information there's
nothing in there nothing behind it and
if people don't realize that whenever
they're hearing story there's an agenda
behind it yeah yeah it doesn't matter
which country's saying it there's always
something like that so it's like yeah
yeah I mean it's because like objective
news is boring you know yes it's boring
and people don't want to read it and
engage with it well a lot of times so
you need to like I guess spice it up and
we do the same things as YouTubers
because you need to like sensationalize
our thumbnails and titles as much as
possible yeah yeah is it was there any
concern with when you're making videos
about like maybe Australian politics
because you know like um friendly
geordies right uh yeah just know this
channel is yeah yeah it covers a bunch
of Australian politics and the kind of
the corruption and stuff going on and
they fire bombed his house they're
discussing well you don't know who right
uh but there's good some good ideas
about who it probably was
um but yeah I mean the dude got his
house they try to kill him yeah is there
any kind of like hey maybe we should
maybe not so we did our money laundering
video with him he was like the original
guy who exposed it yeah yeah and like
potentially they Vibe only because of it
I don't know yeah I can't say who did it
yeah so the fire bombing happened so we
filmed the the timeline was we filmed
with him right then two days later
before we released the video he was
Fireball yeah and then we had to make
the difference I was really scared where
I was like because because
parts of my my it was just Christmas
your gift to me was a fire extinguisher
yeah my mum was a fire extinguisher as
well and she was so chill about it she
was like oh thank you this is great I'll
hang it up in the shoe cupboard I was
like do you know why I'm it's this is in
case organized crime yeah
it's like yeah I know it was it was
quite scary like yeah yeah but I think
it's you know we were lucky that he
friendly geordy's exposed it first yeah
took the heat hopefully literally
and then we were just like yeah it's
happened now you know are they gonna
Fire Bomb another YouTuber
but he was so lucky as well because like
he was they were he was meant to die
like because he was meant to be there
he's someone organized that he like
forgot his keys and he had to go State a
friendship something like that yeah it
doesn't make any sense I mean the
thought that the YouTuber could be
killed or murdered for just talking
about [__] politics is so crazy yeah
to that point where the YouTuber has
that much influence that it would be a
problem
I think what it is is that like
journalists aren't doing their jobs like
no one's reporting on this so the only
one who is is this YouTuber so he's the
one who's gonna get [__] I guess
because there's so much you know with a
lot of journalism
um there's a lot of money yeah that is
Excellence going on right the young
people who really don't have any someone
to answer to is just a random YouTuber
too yeah yeah I'll put my picture
like this is weird that it's come to
this where only independent journalists
can kind of really go after the staff
and afford to yeah although to be fair
after the um fire bombing I think his
subscriber count like doubles oh yeah
it's a little suspicious
I was a good video I watched this video
where he was like who who firebombed
friendly geordies it was a great video
yeah it was a really good video it was
all laid out about it was a really
interesting style he's a very impressive
man like I don't understand if I got
fire bombs it would probably end my
career I'd probably start yeah just like
so so determined yeah it's it's very
important because he also had like one
of his producers got arrested right yeah
yeah yeah this was like a whole big
thing as well like a year ago or
something right yeah they I I'm not too
familiar with it but it was kind of a
crazy thing where he was he was Pro uh
reporting making videos about uh
prominent political figure yeah yeah and
then they got like the terrorism or
special
terrorism's unit yeah to arrest his like
producer so bad it's just like what the
[__] is this it's just the funniest
response when what you're doing is
pointing out corruption and then in
order to fight back like we're gonna do
the most corrupt thing to you right yeah
I'll sell to corruption
you think you've proved our point I mean
it's really impressive that uh yeah I
mean I I it seems that a lot of Aussie
creators are no matter what gets thrown
their way they're just like [__] it
that's just the Aussie you wear right
it's like a very Aussie response they're
trying to ruin your life you're like
I'll just do it more yeah
and then they got the call from my mum
that the police were there searching for
the gun and I was like she was like can
you come home and I was like no I'm
filming a video with a gun at the moment
get back to you and she was like she
thought it was because of the current
video I was filming it was so funny that
yeah the best thing was the police
arrived at the door they asked my mum uh
they were just like oh we're here
because the video Alex has made and then
my mum just starts listing the videos
like nope nope nope yeah it's that one
yeah yeah yeah shortly those police
played it so well because they were kind
of like uh someone for your mum to vent
to like they they're like my crazy son
is always there yeah yeah and I told her
as well I was like mum you don't have to
tell like you know you the police ask
you questions you can remain silent and
as soon as I said that she was like
don't you [__] tell me
if you don't tell me what to say like if
you do I would say whatever I wanted I
was like sorry just please you dot me
and then take me down yeah like to you
know to be a mother to you oh yeah yeah
it's it's pretty bad like the amount of
like when I was uh helping uh yeah no no
that's completely true yeah that's very
reasonable just the amount of things to
fix in that house that was just like I
don't even remember I shot through that
wall because you just shoot through
walls yeah and I'm like how my I just my
mum would beat me
[Music]
she would kill me if I was firing holes
because you'd get a piece of paper you
put glue and you put it on the wall and
then she finds out three years later
when she leans against the wall
she just not watch the videos yeah yeah
she did watch him and then the thing is
you spent all your life kind of micro
dosing her on on like on dangerous
things at least now you're making money
from it so it's kind of like oh I guess
my son's got a job like he's yeah what
do you even think about all this [__]
well I'm lucky that my mum is very
supportive of all of it and was kind of
like she had a job that she hated she
was an accountant so I guess in her
opinion she was like just be anything
besides an accountant please see when
the literal opposite yeah yeah so before
you made this your job but how did your
mom react to you [__] doing all the
[__] as a kid oh so I think as a kid I
was just hiding it a lot oh I'm just
trying like that is the Strat that is
just sneaking out then doing it like
after school I would take days off just
skip school to go do that right
um
this is not normal
but I'm making money from McConnell
the bombs that I made as a kid was just
the precursor to making money yeah
the internet yeah he would have become
famous either from YouTube or he would
have just been a
you were doing this but you were 15
years younger like 15 years before there
was no YouTube as an outlet you would
have just been like all right guys Isis
a guy that was in swat I was doing I
forgot what I was doing I was doing some
job before YouTube and he said to me
he was just like you remind me exactly
of the of all the guys that get caught
making meth yeah
probably that's probably what you do
before you do yeah
oh my gosh that's like the second one
she was a Nigel Nigel was like that
Nigel was like meth is rookie I've asked
him so many times I'm like please Nigel
like make math
yeah
he could like I made meth out of cotton
candy or like you know
he would be it would be so easy for him
we asked him about it he was like no no
it's too easy yeah it's pretty easy it's
not exciting I'm gonna make uranium yeah
yeah yeah she's talking about uranium
and stuff you're like this sounds bad
yeah and it also seems like you get the
authorities calling you for like the
weirdest things because he got one chord
in him like the government side like
looking into him for a uh I think it's
like a test tube or something right it's
like a specific type of tube that you
would commonly use for making that yeah
um but it's like test stupid [__]
tampon gun sounds like the government
doesn't at least in when Canada where he
was like the government doesn't regulate
the really [__] crazy stuff it's like
no one should be able to get this anyway
yeah so there wasn't a lot of Regulation
around like uranium yeah who the [__]
can get uranium like you shouldn't be
able to get it so like why like we just
they just didn't think about making
rules
No One's Gonna enrich uranium even if
you get the uranium you can't you can't
yeah
I'm doing uh
do you want to make uh like this
I want us to do this video still
okay okay
I've been a video where you were
concerned or you're like you this is too
much yeah I don't want him doing any
videos
yeah that was really bad that's probably
the one where it's the noise and the
kind of like sharing I don't know what
it was like the reverberation in the
room of just like
and then that getting faster it was like
the dumbest thing ever because you you
had the ceiling fan with machetes that
were spinning at only a speed that I can
imagine so and then as your defense you
have this tiny piece of plywood that was
underneath and you were underneath it
and I'm like this even if it hit this
it's gonna go right it would go right
through it what are you doing you stand
in front of it and just go like all
right let's see
my logic was that because it was
spinning at high speed and it was above
me it would almost be impossible how
does the blade get down it could bounce
off something there if it bounced but
then the speed would be taken out of it
would be a lot but I was like it would
fly through one of the walls or the
garage wall where my brothers were
standing not me so I think I think Alex
was like a living example of what is it
was it survivor bias or whatever
all these things that should have killed
him and he just assumes that
everything's safe now
oh my God don't say this I'm gonna die
now yeah
I tell him every day oh my God
has there ever been a video you came up
with where it's just like no this would
actually kill me if I tried to do it
yeah some so after I made the I made a
video uh where I made a Jacob's Ladder
which is where you got a bunch of
microwave um Transformers put them
together and you create incredibly high
voltage because you're like you're doing
it parallel right yeah I'm playing with
a dumb amount of amps so much that it
would kill you instantly yeah yeah I
don't know and then I wanted to make
some more videos with um electricity one
of them was doing this thing forgotten
the exact name now but it's called like
lithographic art
and it goes like yeah great cool
patterns I wanted to to do some cool
versions of that yeah
um and then I was like no it's just not
worth it how far did you get into the
video before your life oh I had made all
of it except for for actually doing the
art and I was like no I should it's not
that interesting and it's not worth the
risk so that's why it was kind of like
if it was interesting enough I probably
would have done it it didn't explode so
it's
doesn't go boom I think boy boy though
has some good better examples of stuff
where we're like can we just yeah
because you it's gonna I mean it's a
different yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
just Society is this acceptable Society
yeah yeah will my body survive yeah yeah
you're constantly putting everything on
the line yeah yeah yeah well with boy
boy we had it we were seriously
considering going to Afghanistan to film
with the Taliban yeah
oh my God
recently what the [__] as soon as as
soon as America pulled out we're like no
more war this is the time
we'll like we'll go talk to the Taliban
see what's happening so so what do you
like
every single country collect like do not
go through everything we cannot help you
if you go there that's what they said
about North Korea and so like
they came back with a fresh cut you
could just tell the Taliban hey here's
all my details
um
[Music]
literally a couple of weeks ago when a
guy got kidnapped YouTubers got taken
hostage by the time yeah that was when
we're like is it the British guy yeah I
think British guy did not bowled in
bankrupt no he was Lord
did the other guy the guy who bought one
of those okay this this dude was [__]
weird
it's like a 4chan kid who yeah he bought
one of those shitty established titles
scam things and somehow actually managed
to convince his bank to put Lord that's
why he's lost he went around actually
like because then his bank had done it
so it's really easy to get everyone else
to recognize the Lord thing yeah and
then he went to Afghanistan and was
vlogging and then it was like a whole
[__] situation he was just unhinged yeah
it was clearly yeah come to me everybody
let's see we do it in the non on here
yeah we could be the normal ones he
clearly was just mental illness just in
Afghanistan yeah he seemed a bit of like
a psychotic episode turned into a
YouTube yeah like he clearly had like
needed some attention and it took it to
an extreme level and he was just hanging
around like vlogging when he was with
the Taliban yeah because he already had
a video out and we saw that and we're
like oh this is we can do this this is
easy and it turns out because pushed him
too far and that's the thing it's you
don't know until you're there and
there's there's a lot of different
factions and infighting whatever yeah
the end of the day like what do you like
I mean from a from a um what is the what
would you get out of it like what would
you no I don't think because it's not
like we love the talents
are you actually getting anything out of
this or is it just because like you're
like you know it's like I don't know
what we're getting out of it but [__]
what's the angle well I think I think
yeah I mean we usually have a vaguely
like where where we have a lot of
opinions on the wall like I think it was
a horrible thing yeah yeah um and I
guess just going there is like a gimmick
and then we've got an excuse to talk
about it no literally like Afghanistan
for a bit this is a great YouTube
thumbnail like we joined the Taliban or
something I was like what and then you
watch it and then you see like our whole
spiel about the Afghan war and then yeah
the trick people into this just on
average it would be Sunday
yeah
he's a freak dude yeah he's just weird
so this YouTuber that got kidnapped what
what happened is he still I think he
might still be kidnapped
violent have we not heard about this I
don't know he's barely a YouTuber yeah
he's got nothing yeah
I think when it's like it's like that
kind of character it makes it worse when
you give that there's going on yeah yeah
you're enabling him whenever you're
talking about what he's doing yeah I
mean but it's like it's one of those
things that when you're I guess it comes
up and it's relevant now but it's like
you don't want to give this [__] dude
attention because it's exactly what he
[__] wants yeah but I think he was
trying to push it like we make jokes I
think we we still try to do things that
are relatively safe yeah but he really
did just push it a lot where he was like
what did you want here what was your end
goal I think you can go to some of these
countries if you have a local fixer yeah
but I think he literally was just she
just [__] no show up there running
around just going around doing whatever
you want I mean you know yeah a lot of
the time you do need a fixer which is
the hard part I think yeah often
YouTubers who do go to these places
don't show that they have a fixer or not
yeah yeah they're like oh yeah I found
this all out where it's like some dude
has literally got you on a leash being
like yes it's literally saving your life
needs something to do it alone I've got
money yeah yeah um yeah it's pretty
crazy yeah aside from Afghanistan as and
beaten been any other videos I just feel
like you want to go to Warzone yeah yeah
you're doing like real life journalism
now like straight out it's pretty yeah
it's pretty cool it's like you guys are
really going out there and and Josh
documenting this stuff but also it's so
sarcastic and so downplayed that it
almost feels like this is unreal yeah
that's that's the whole thing because I
find I don't know personally that I mean
there are other people that do some kind
of Journalism but like I just find it so
boring when they're not if you're not
making jokes it's like who are you even
you're talking to people who are
interested in the news who already know
all this [__] yeah like if you're making
jokes it's like you're actually talking
to people who who aren't going to listen
to any of this you know like we wouldn't
otherwise listen to anything yeah but um
to answer your question it's kind of
it's kind of we're gonna sound super
dodgy but there are places that we
wanted to go that we still want to go
that we can't talk about because if we
tell you then we'll we'll be stopped
from going there
yeah we shouldn't even say that much
[__] Australian government you're
leaving yeah yeah please stop please go
to a nice place
oh my God how long are you until you
guys want to watch this oh well I found
someone released on Twitter someone that
works at a security
Expo or something like that or just
worked in government surveillance or
security released a took a photo of a
slideshow that was playing in a security
conference which was a threat assessment
of one of my videos and had like a
rating it was the video where I I used
drones to drop metal darts from 200
meters and showed that you could Pierce
a car and be fairly accurate with them
and then someone did a assessment on it
was like security threat it wasn't that
high it was like a four out of ten four
hours
you had a crazy one from that video
because someone used exactly the same
mechanism that was scary in the war in
Ukraine someone sent me a video and it
was like the same I mean it's a pretty
simple concept it was just drone takes
up something drops it drops it using the
the light the same yeah it was weird
because I used um because mavic doesn't
have like a trigger mechanism or way to
trigger anything except for you can turn
on and off a light yeah so I just had an
Arduino which had a light sensor so when
you when you turn on the light then that
triggers a Servo motor which opens the
arm and you can drop something and then
someone used it like exactly the same
and even like it just looked like it was
the same the same um 3D printed file and
I was like oh that's a bit I used to
drop grenades in on Russians or maybe
Russians on Ukrainian so you think maybe
they got inspiration from your video or
I mean I I don't know I think it's a
pretty dropping stuff from this yeah
yeah yeah pretty common concept but it
was a bit like oh that's right the video
has eight million views so there's a
chance that someone's watching oh my God
God great yeah you should take credit
for your good work yeah wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't for you
I'm responsible yeah oh God instead of
sneaking into an arms convention would
just be we ran in arms yeah we started
an arm convention right now
what a character development you went
from just blowing [__] up in your yard
or whatever to now I guess making uh
everyone starts somewhere right yeah
did you oh my God both of your guys's
ideas are like what's wrong with you
both
so unhinged dude do you have any video
ideas for Japan though yeah we've got a
good one we want to do because I think
in um Japan there's the big culture of
salary man
um and talking about how Japan's such an
interesting place where it's so high
energy and fun and then on the other
hand you have high suicide rate
depressed people yeah stuck in the same
job so I think we wanted to do a job
where Alexa and I become salary men so
live exactly the lifestyle
Connor we want to we want yeah we
haven't pitched this is us
working for College salary man then we
get drunk become smellier and smellier
more dishes we sleep in internet cafes
internet cafes and you can get those uh
pre-iron suits and 7-Elevens or
something oh yeah can we just see how
long we can last like yeah see what it's
like it's not very easy to drink a lot
yeah yeah yeah it's a lot of times yeah
what's like the limit for that though I
don't know I think is awake as long as
Conor is
it's minimum wage
like yeah if you're working at part-time
at like a 7-Eleven it's like 700 Yen an
hour okay that's seven dollars an hour
it's like six seven dollars now yeah
what is it Kelly 561 yeah
it's like nine dollars an hour [__] that
is not nine dollars an hour in this
economy I think you saw an Australian
dollar oh Australian dollar yeah but and
in Japan's higher cost of living than
Australia in terms of what you get per
dollar or is it see I've heard that but
I'm not too sure because like my general
consensus is that Australia is just way
too expensive certain things are way
more expensive in Japan and certain
things are a lot cheaper so like yeah
like eating out is really cheap but also
certain food items are very cheap but
maybe stuff that we're more used to
eating that we kind of get really cheap
it's a little bit more expensive I think
maybe it's the whole thing of like the
rent is expensive for how much space
outside of Japan it's very cheap very
affordable
um but also you're not near anything oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know well
that's that's why there was this whole
craze about you can buy really really
cheap houses in Japan yeah but just like
the the catches that you're in the
middle of [__] nowhere and you have
to and you have to live your own
Fukushima yeah
sure there are plenty of houses there
yeah oh man yeah yeah not good not a
good area if you I mean it's fine now
but obviously you don't know what the
consequences are yeah yeah exactly
um but but no Japan's a cool place
though yeah I'd like to say never been
and yeah it's so close I don't know I
think that is not close well I've got a
closer relative to oh I guess yeah from
everything yeah it was a 20-hour flight
from everything yeah and I think it's
because maybe China was the more
unhinged like the more interesting
version
of China yeah yeah why why China
[Music]
like whereabouts have you been in China
kind of over the place all over
um I don't even know we started up the
first time we went like up north Beijing
like into Mongolia my parents were
actually born in habin which is in
northern China right because they were
Russian immigrants that got kicked out
of Russia and they lived in China so
it's kind of like a place where I'm like
oh it'd be interesting to see you know
what any Russian stuff left there and
it's like no now there's just a city of
10 million people and like nothing left
it's like crazy yeah wow this is a cool
place love the food everyone's like
hilarious
um yeah everyone like is really friendly
I don't know it's probably like Japan a
bit where like people are just really
excited to see white people so you're a
bit kind of like cheating where you're
just like you rock up to a village I
think I'd be trying to more so than
Japan I think oh yeah yeah yeah
[__] times they're sick of it and
China's just so massive the thing I
really love about it is you can go to a
city with like you know the same
population as Sydney but yeah once seen
a white person before yeah it's just
crazy like it's how is there that many
people here but it's like so it's just
its own thing I don't know I mean I
guess like the politics around the
country have kind of made it pretty kind
of yeah yeah when was the last time you
went to China
we'll actually filmed a video in a wet
Market in China yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh just before covers
what were you filming in was it just
about the wet markets uh it's kind of
dodgy this is a video that
exploring why we're so offended with
Chinese people eating dogs when we
ourselves together to eat so much meat
yeah and to explain what's the
difference is it is there actually a
difference between a dog and a pig and
then exploring the cultural reason as to
like
why we just like pinning it on Chinese
gonna piss a lot of people off that
video oh yeah I think it's hard because
dogs are such lovely animals and we love
dogs and it's like you know but it's
hard I feel like if you lived with a pet
pig you'd have exactly the same
relationship like yeah pretty they're
very smart very cute yeah yeah like I
know a lot of people who don't eat pork
uh including my mother-in-law just
because you know they
um they were just like I can't do I see
the pigs same way they see his dogs yeah
I mean religion as well you know yeah
religion as well yeah that's the thing
when we were there we were at the
festival like interviewing a bunch of
people a lot of a lot of guys were just
like
westerners don't eat dogs Indians don't
eat cows it's the same thing
um we're just like yeah well I mean fair
enough well people pretty open and just
talking on camera there it was
surprising that people would like yeah
[__] it I guess they don't know anybody
no they had some good opinions about it
as well and like somebody like some dumb
adults they're like oh we only eat the
bad dogs
and the obsession with it making you you
better at sex oh yes
this guy was just like yeah really good
at sex and then he offered the dog's
penis to Alexa
oh that was so trippy so I I was eating
a dog's penis and uh
it was what you don't realize or maybe
you guys know this I don't know but
they've got this thing called a baculum
which is like they have a bone inside
there oh yeah I didn't know that would
you say yeah yeah yeah like you're like
yeah I'm trying a dog's penis I mean
I've owned many dogs but in my head I
was like oh it's just it's like my penis
and I just bit straight through it and
like almost like chipped a tooth on a
dog's penis so I didn't realize I was
just a hard bone inside oh [__] guys
what I'm sorry that's probably the wrong
thing
the ideas I just love the opening to
that sense
the angle was we wanted to interview all
these people there and I think coming in
as a Westerner the idea is that you're
there as an activist and you're trying
to stop people from eating dogs so like
in order to get the best interviews we
were you're eating it we were eating it
yeah well I ate like two kilos we ate so
much yeah I like actually became
vegetarian for like two years
just so sake of like just eating meat
yeah I feel like I'm doing like an
undercover Cup right now who's like you
had to try all the drugs
yeah it's like it's like kind of like
Luther a little bit right he'll do
whatever you know you know if they're a
pawn worker he'll go and do everything
except the pawn they'll do everything
else around it right yeah sure yeah I
think you know if you are willing to
show people that you're not judgmental
it's just like hey can you can you just
I want to just honestly know why why you
do this and I'm not coming here to like
Runner yeah yeah it's like hey could you
just tell me and I'll yeah and it's like
it is confronting and especially like
seeing dogs you're just like [__] this
is this is yeah this is horrible but
like at the same time like they found it
confronting just a quantity of meat that
we eat like yeah yeah right they eat so
much less like it's such a smaller part
of meals over there yeah
I mean it was uh I mean so presumably
they were all speaking in Chinese how
did you now
that helps a lot how do you go about
finding a fixer for like a certain
country he was just a guy that had just
made just posted on social media right I
think he actually studied in America
yeah and then he was a guy we saw
brought in a couple of friends and then
the Hebrew it was actually just it was
funny because it was his friends and
they there was just too many people
there and everyone was doing different
things and it was really it's really
hard I'm sure you guys have probably
worked in countries we don't speak the
same language it's so hard to
communicate what you want oh yeah
especially with working with real people
who are doing something else yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it was like but we
managed to get some footage to talk to
people and yeah just awesome just cool
yeah I'm curious because I haven't been
to China since they added like the whole
social credit kind of system
how bad is like the surveillance there
nowadays we found it interesting because
we we didn't really there were some
rules you meant to follow in China one
of them is you meant to let the
government know which hotels you're
checking into we didn't do that the
entire time but we didn't get in trouble
I honestly I feel like it might be a bit
overblown because it felt a lot more
chill than I expected
yeah but that's the thing is you can't
go in on a journalistic Visa oh yes
you're not allowed so when we were going
in we're going in as tourist visas
filming undercover not you know not
telling people what you're doing and
then when we did have interactions with
the police you just kind of pretend
you're not
so at the festival we were filming and
obviously we're not meant to uh yeah but
a cop came out to us and it was just so
chill like I don't even took a photo
with us yeah yeah yeah because they were
like there's a fan you asked us if we
were activists and we're like no we're
not here we're just we're here to eat
some dog meat yeah
I was confused they were just like oh
okay you can kind of stay there
yeah it's a weird comparison though
because like I think it is quite chill
for us to go there it I think they come
down real hard on domestic journalists
as a foreigner I think there's just like
it's too much of a PR disaster for them
to do anything they're pretty relaxed
yeah the guy we were chatting to our
fixer he really didn't want to talk
about politics in China because he was
like it's just it's scary to do it yeah
for sure like how did you go about
filming covertly because I guess you
can't just [__] rock up with dslrs
we've had it one time like the end of
the trip we would walk walking through
this random
um village I forgot where it was it was
just outside of you Lynn um and we came
across the Sweatshop where these these
kind of like mothers were working and
they actually had their kids kind of
like playing in the sweatshops as well
mucking around on machines and we just
walked into the sweatshop
sat down on a sewing machine and just
started pretending to make things and
were filming and these everyone just
found it hilarious strange
it was just working in a sweatshop it
was so funny like yeah that's all that's
all going to be in the video
do you ever stop to think like this is
[__] insane like what we're doing is
so [__] yeah some of those people
you're like yeah that's what's going to
be worse
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by Incognito here's the scenario for you
Connor say for instance Conor's
traveling in America and out of a
combination of pure absolute desperation
and just being Connor he eats a petrol
station hot dog aside from the crazy
things that would happen to his stomach
the last thing he would want is for
every other petrol station in the world
to know about it then flood his
Instagram with ads about petrol station
hot dogs why it's not a true nightmare
scenario right Connor yes well that's
pretty much what happens every time
you're online thousands of companies are
collecting aggregating and trading your
personal data without you knowing
anything about it you actually have the
right to request data Brokers to delete
what information they have about you and
protect your privacy the bad news
however boys it would take you years to
do a manually literal year that's where
incognit comes in Incognito can do the
messy work for you automatically
incognitive helps you protect your
privacy and takes your personal data off
the market by reaching out to data
Brokers on your behalf requesting your
personal data removal and dealing with
their objections to check it out go to
incognet.com use code trash taste to get
an exclusive offer of 60 off that's
incompany.com trash tease and use code
trash tease just click the link in the
description guys back to the episode so
when you travel to these countries you
actually go with a journalism Visa most
of the time now
No
One's Gonna Give it to us
[Music]
like BBC or whatever yeah
right and also it just takes a long time
because so like with with China it's
like there's a vague possibility that we
could have gotten a journalist Visa if
we waited like a year or two I imagine
you're under more scrutiny though yeah
exactly that's the point of it because
you're going there to do journalism
possibly criticizing a country so it's
weird for a country to be like yeah come
on in criticize it and they do do it but
obviously then they're watching you and
I think it's also we live in an age
where like consumer grade uh video
technology is very good right now yeah
so like as there's no real difference
between what we use and what like an
ambitious tourist uses it's really
concerned for being banned from certain
countries or yeah or getting arrested
you know some video ideas like the one
we're not talking about yeah where it's
like yeah you can do stuff and then if
you know piss off the wrong people yeah
you just get banned from America or Okay
and like right right right yeah damn
what's your opinion like modern day
journalism then because if it kind of
feels like you are trying to bring a new
angle to journalism trying to make some
jokes trying to do it like a different
direction to every other like I guess
mainstream news Outlet does yeah I think
I think there's some big blind spots
like there's I mean there's a lot of
good journalism out there still it's
pretty rare in my opinion but the
biggest one is like anti-war stuff is
doesn't exist like it's it's so freaky
like especially I mean what we're
concerned right now is with like China
or with China it's just like everyone's
set on it everyone's like we're going to
war like every news article is like it's
gonna happen and even like the ABC
government and stuff or or SBS news
channels in Australia that are meant to
be like balanced balanced it's like just
pushing for war and everyone kind of
forgets it's like a lot of journalists
are just like almost trying to justify
either side it's like no no this is
never good it's like you watched on
Ukraine it's like no no just the whole
thing's bad like war is never good like
it's not let's not do War yeah avoid
that at every cost um yeah because it
gets clicks right Wars scary and
scariest you know that's that's kind of
where a lot of Journalism is at right
now it's just about sensationalizing
yeah getting people angry or worked up
or scared yeah yeah also I think it's
like um it's so incestuous in that like
so many of these big media companies are
funded by the same the same like
companies essentially or like they're
all sponsored by different things it's
just like it's they have like really
strict limits to how much they can move
and who they can who they can um what
companies they can trade on the toes of
it's like yeah you use the word
incestuously yes right I was like
my mind went places
no it's insane that you know some of
what it feels like
modern day you know legitimate
journalism is being just done by some
random guys on YouTube now like I think
back to like you know channel five uh
yeah yeah started off doing like [__]
interviews of like the craziest
conventions you can find in America and
then one day I go on my YouTube and he's
like in Ukraine yeah yeah talking to
some of the survivors yeah that was
crazy or some of the refugees and I'm
like [__] this is this what modern day
journalism is like turning into now yeah
I mean I remember doing the black lives
matter protest he was like he was just
in a store it was on fire yeah yeah
and you notice like journalists could be
doing this like there's nothing stopping
you from doing this it's like it's yeah
it's pretty impressive it's yeah it's
insane it's not just all because like
you said they're just being paid by
people they don't want to tread on their
toes yeah right right yeah uh have you
ever been banned from a country or no
yet yet I was in Singapore I got banned
for
two weeks I think it was 14 days because
when um I had been doing a trip me and
Alexa traveled through China and then
Russia and then into
um I was in Bosnia and there was a war
there and um I was just walking this
random town and I found bullets on the
ground so I put the bullets in my bag
why did
forgot about them traveled a bunch then
in Singapore that's when they found the
bullets and then they interrogated me
not not it wasn't and then they saw your
YouTube channel and they're all like it
was before this was before YouTube oh so
why the [__] were you would roaming
around Bosnia and Russia oh this was
just for fun I mean I've got family back
here oh yeah
Alexa's family and then I just wanted to
check out the area and there's a cool
place called most star and there was a
there was Civil War there right yeah and
then Singapore like found the things and
I think I got a 14-day ban which isn't
very much that's like nothing nothing
but they said if I bring weapons in
again or bullets and then I face prison
time oh they literally did a twitch band
for you yeah
stream is like
it's like going back no bullet system
you're the only dude I know who would
just pick bullets up after the floor
and get about it they're interesting I
don't understand but also like what kind
of clumsy terrorists they think you are
like you've gone and done training with
some militia and you're like whoops
accidentally kept mine yeah they asked
me they're like have you been training
with terrorist organizations I was like
no I don't think so maybe
yeah
the family business
so you guys have obviously done a lot of
traveling even like before YouTube how
many places have you been to then I
don't know maybe I think I've probably
been to 20. that's pretty [__]
impressive yeah it's not that much
compared to like the people that
consider themselves Travelers you know
yeah on YouTube have done like 150 close
to 198 countries well I think our issue
is we used to travel a lot and then as
soon as we went to China we're just like
well I guess we're just gonna keep going
to China making content as well now
that's true now I almost get a bit
annoyed when I've traveled to a place
and I've I like I find it really hard to
find a reason to take a holiday I almost
get a bit bored where I'm like yeah I
could be making something yeah
becomes a bit of a Content yeah well
like when traveling becomes part of your
content you're like well I could be
could be working right now yeah this is
unoptimized and it gives you a mission
as well it's like playing a video game
where you have a quest and you're like
yeah I'm not just traveling because I
want to sit on a beach and get drunk or
pull you know yeah we used to do that we
used to have a little Quest even before
we would making content like when we
when we're in China
um the first time they had this this
thing around Beijing potentially in
other cities where um
uh I think because like nuclear war they
they decided to build all these bunkers
um and now they're kind of like unused
but there's like whole bunker system
underneath Beijing that's like Linked UP
And um just really hard to find and we
spent like weeks just looking for these
things but like now we look back like
[__] I would have made a nice video but
yeah you ended up finding them and they
were and I found them by accident I was
staying in this this um just Airbnb and
then one day I just walked underneath
one of the apartments and I was like oh
that looks like the the symbol for bomb
shelter and you go I went underneath and
then there was just like tunnels and you
walked through like the the atomic
bunker doors and then there was just
people living in these bunkers
underneath Beijing and they're like
total action I'm like dude I found the
bunkers
none of this was recorded you're
sleeping in your bunker
and a six foot four white guy and just
doesn't look around he's like [__]
totally happens
I was like we need to go back and then
I'm walking through the bun because I'm
walking deeper and deeper and then I'm
like realizing like I am in someone's
house someone's cooking and she's
looking at me I'm like I'm a monster
like what am I doing here this is just
amusing for me this poverty porn and me
being like yeah
oh my God so this was before you started
what is your ideal holiday yes
most people they like going to the beach
you know chill out with their cocktails
is there a country you want to go to
that's not necessarily linked to content
or is it always just like yeah it's all
content now our brain's been melted so
it's participated with the bizarre and
the weird yeah experiences yeah yeah and
then yeah meeting the people there and
then showing their way of life to me
yeah it was pretty cool is there any
like cool countries you went to before
like you started traveling for content
probably not no I love Cuba but that's
that's another thing
where you can't go into like the US
right so can you go now you can actually
but I think there's some still some
limitations around Cuba in some sense
yeah yeah I'm not exactly sure what
um but yeah I mean other than that do
you guys watch anime
I do actually I was a bit of a when I
was growing up I loved Ohio mazaki I
still really like yeah
Ghibli gilby Philly
[__] kill me yeah
and then I watched a lot of Naruto
um I watched bleach uh oh hell yeah I
watched one uh one piece I watched um
Death Note nice to watch because that's
uh you know when you say you watch One
Piece that that means a lot of things
you know how far did you I didn't watch
that much one piece I watched a lot of
Naruto I watched like
Seven Seasons eight seasons it was like
a hundred I think it was like 160 180 I
was up to yeah that's that's a lot like
300 episodes
which is like the longest season how far
did you get
I don't remember where I got up to but
yeah around 180 or something I remember
[__] no it's a lot yeah yeah that's
that's a that's a lot of episodes more
than Connor yeah
I really do know what are you watch
anime yeah I was I mean like barely I I
watched heaps of it doesn't even count I
watched heaps of Dragon Ball Z Pokemon
as a kid that's like that but before
before coming on here I'm like I gotta
do the crash course I gotta go
um literally well I just ended up
watching all the Studio Ghibli films
again but um but um no what I did find
was Cowboy Bebop and I'm like this is
the coolest thing I've ever seen
I was like what have I been doing all my
life it's like yeah yeah I loved it yeah
yeah it's good and what's annoying have
you watched the new um what's the the
what's the one that's copied off the
computer game um
I was just like this is just Cowboy
Bebop but worse yeah
oh
is just bounty hunters bounty hunters
I don't know you don't think so I I I I
I you know
that's the first time I've ever heard
that comparison
I've made that comparison as well uh but
I actually prefer cyberpunk I don't know
I I think I think Cowboy Bebop is great
but I like having like an ongoing
storyline oh yeah yeah Cowboy Bebop was
just like every episode like
self-contained yeah uh and though you
know that was cool they had some like
really cool [__] ideas but cyberpunk
was just like a group of bounty hunters
and you see their Journey from like
beginning to end yeah that was cool yeah
holy [__] some of those scenes that's
cool yeah yeah some of those scenes in
uh cyber Farm were just so insane the
opening scene of the shows yeah yeah
yeah adult scenes were just awesome it's
like yeah did you play the game as well
no I didn't my brother played it but he
just complained about the glitches it
was so bad I'm not touching this
also it's hard with video games because
like I get obsessed and if I if I
download it I'm just not going to make
videos ever again you have to keep it
safe you know yeah yeah that's the tough
part do you still game a lot or not I
don't do any I play online chess
the greatest game that's the original
patch in thousands of years man
they've not needed to patch that or
anything
yeah
it's pretty weeby that's pretty that's
pretty anime yeah yeah that's pretty
deep in the sauce sick what's your
favorite uh Studio gilby anime I I
reckon probably princess okay yeah or or
a house moving yes anti-war kind of yeah
I really liked how I was moving Castle
watch so many times but princess
just the nature I'm gonna say the most
basic but I really like Spirited Away
spirit away
I haven't seen Spirited Away you should
watch well you've never seen Spirited
Away no I just know all the screenshots
I've never seen uh princess Mom okay I
think I lied and said I saw it one time
on the podcast I felt pressured to watch
it
I watch a lot of them actually wow yeah
I mean you're not a real Studio Ghibli
fan are you Connor no yeah we've talked
about this before but how is that he's
kind of a dick and it kind of puts me
off he's a d yeah yeah
this is like this is like my my thing
like my uh some people are like that's
[__] based but I don't know why this
pissed me off so much his son made a
movie and he went to the premiere and he
walked out halfway through I was like
it is literally a scene he walks out of
the cinema lights a cigarette and he's
like he's still got a long way to go
he's like he's still not ready Cool
that's like an anime
he was right
develop [__]
no matter how much you you just got to
be like all right all right you know
your son comes back with a drawing and
like it's like hey hey Dad I made this
bro you know they're like five years old
or something you know it's like a [__]
drawing all right do you do you lie and
say this is amazing son well if they're
five yeah but like you know yeah
nicely it's got to be a bit of
encouragement with a bit of oh you could
be better this could be better you know
like I don't know it's the fact that he
didn't even like tell his son it was
[__] he just walked out you know yeah he
just walks out now he is the dad that
went out for cigarettes and never came
back
yeah that makes me like him more
yeah people hear that and you like him
more or they I think that's awesome yeah
it's like it's like Jackie Chan you know
have you have you ever like heard about
his son's life oh yeah yeah yeah it's
just under drugs right that's very
illegal yeah yeah he was like he was
like the Ambassador for like and like
anti-drugs and like he's like I did not
claim my son yeah yeah yeah and his son
got caught like doing weed or something
yeah uh in his apartment and uh yeah the
more I found out the more I found out
about it the more I found out yo he just
wasn't there for his kids he was just
never yeah he was just a [__] dad
um
if you're gonna be a bad father he
probably picked the coolest way to do it
like the stuff he was doing when he
wasn't with his kids
for Humanity yeah like we got sick films
a lot of bad dads are just like I don't
know doing drugs somewhere like this
yeah
my dad's a bad daddy he doesn't even
know how to do cool fight choreography
do you like anything
I when I was a child I like hold on
hold on hold up hold up hold up when I
was four I don't know 16 I was like oh
yeah hentai's cool
not for me not for me anymore I missed I
missed out on hentai I feel like I
watched like cartoon porn as a as a team
but I needed more like [__] like
Marge Simpson yeah exactly that's
exactly what it is
it's the weird ads you see
you watched those yeah I did when I was
a kid look it doesn't do it for me
anymore but like I I the fact that it
did it for you at any point yeah it's
concerning I was very connected to these
characters you know it was like
it's like Japanese comes from Japan
no no I watch actual Japanese hentai how
did you find out how did how did you
discover it yeah I remember there was a
guy from in our school who would bring
hentai to school and the teacher's desk
he would walk up when he was asking you
a question oh is this dick head type is
this Ouija this is Ouija yeah stick
hentai to the front and then no one knew
and then we would just stare at hentai
four lessons
and then after that I was like wow
this guy who knows
he's good he's got the goods we've done
some rap shows where we've reviewed
hentai
I can't remember what I was trying to
download but it was probably some some
music or something and you know instead
of getting like Bill Clinton's like we
did back in the day uh I just discovered
this hentai and I was like what is this
wire to find the next episode remember
how you discovered it
it might have been the same honestly I
think it was like yeah it was like oh
yeah no I remember I was at my friend's
place and he was trying to like show me
like this new Linkin Park song or
whatever and uh and he was like oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna let's I'll try and find
it on LimeWire and then he downloaded it
and it was yeah an episode of um [__]
Live Wire yeah of whatever hentai was
and I was just like whoa this
and then I went home and searched it up
and that's how I found it because I
didn't even know it was called hentai
you know back in the day right because
like you know that this this was back
when a lot of people didn't know that
anime was called anime hence I was
called hentai was just weird [__]
[__] from China
it's Chinese cartoons yeah yeah and uh I
remember because you know not many
people talked about anime and hentai
back in the day
um I remember I was out with some mates
out in uh out of the pub and we were you
know getting a few drinks uh and we were
like so guys what's uh what's the
biggest thing that you've jacked off to
that you regret and then one of my mate
goes
dude one time I jacked off to anime porn
and everyone's like oh you're [__]
sick mate what the [__] and I'm just
here sitting in silence being like
um yeah that's uh that's that's weird
man that's mad that's that's weird
that's [__] gross
oh my God so what's next for you guys
what are you guys you guys planning
anything big or just yeah
I don't know well I mean we've got the
China doco the dog meat Festival
um coming out hopefully in a month uh
yeah we've got some different boy boy
ideas some big videos but it's hard with
the travel ones because it's just it
takes so long yeah yeah high risk and
then got some idea to thing videos as
well you can do so any collaborations
with other content creators hopefully
hopefully it's always fun doing that
jumpy welcome to me and be a salary man
yeah whatever you need it bad office
workers
Jesus Christ you see terrified yeah
we really put you on the spot pitching
on the podcast
someone's going to keep you out of
trouble in Japan
You'll Rock up you'll have like face
tattoos and everything like so we've
joined them
it's really fascinating
yeah
oh my God anything you want to shout out
before we wrap it up no I guess it's
checking out the channel check out the
Channel Boy and um all right well good
well thanks coming on guys
hey look at all these patrons though you
see yeah they're they're all on the
screen right oh that's a lot of patrons
Bill Bill
that's all I know all right well thank
you so much for coming on guys yeah
hey if you want to support the show then
make sure to go to our patreon
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you had our face listen
to us on Spotify and uh yeah thanks guys
for coming out thank you very much this
has been the living definition of [__]
around and find out yeah
all right well bye guys bye
[Music]
thank you